hey everyone we're here for our last
wine day of the season into these things
can you believe it oh my god I'm joined
once again by ESA's Ryder dye my lead
actress Yvonne orgy okay this was an
eventful season we are so excited to get
into it this episode has ISA going for
it professionally and feeling
comfortable with her friends even as she
faces down 30 y'all Nathan came back
what he burn out he goes I'm gonna be
you said him away so like what was up
with that cuz he had no right girl it's
your 30th birthday why this do like it's
a real dude
girls just are to you and I wasn't
looking out for you when you're not
calling or texting for a whole month get
out of here no you don't care about me I
don't care what's going on you like do
better but it was rooted in other things
like money was bringing her own baggage
and to rule me appreciated Somali
suggestion okay but ISA was spun out
over this dude she's at a point where
she's like I want to make decisions for
myself and I want to have clarity and it
felt like Molly was bringing her own
issue but it was a bad decision
like buddy's about your sake I feel like
Molly's like her you deserve the best
like Molly thinks the world of ISA she
thinks that like we're gonna be adults
we should be the same way like drovers
trash like oh you you don't have a baby
look at then what you didn't even give
him a chance to explain this whole child
come in I think Molly too sometimes
especially given what she said in
Episode seven about like dudes are gonna
say whatever they you'll need to hear
his explanation yeah sure whatever cool
sound right to make a whole month of
disappearin sound amazing right or
normal and girls fall for all the time
and I think that's where molly is coming
from so it rhesus negative you go well I
looked at Molly that's not right for
Daniel she's not right for her Nathan
but she [ __ ] the Lord I think Molly is
okay with Laurence not being in the
picture that's why that's why she was
like oh we back we good like how do we
feel but I think she's not okay when
they think being the replacement so the
one thing that we always talked about in
the room we want to say like Molly after
three years like we want this kind of
put Molly into a relation
or at least the the like the blossoming
of something that could be like Oh could
this work and we were in the room a lot
of times about she'd be like should he
be then she'd be that who would this be
if he was Asian like he's like what does
that do for a character like kind of
like take her out of her comfort so I
think with my Louie I would really like
challenge her way of thinking right like
okay if it's not a fairy tale is that ok
ok if it's not does it have to be this
sort of like you know I'm in the upper
relationship type of thing it's the idea
of a true came up and we really were
sort of like we really want to make sure
that we don't just make Molly be this
sort of tragic woman you know but that
was a real thing for us we wanted to
sort of give it you know buddy buddy
okay but if it's gonna be a guy who's
not black how do we explore that big and
I think Alexander the guy who plays
Andrew he's great in so many ways I
think Molly
Molly's that chick whom I need somebody
with you say hey yeah if you like you
need a hug don't make me hug you you
know like these she's that chick that
like needs the reverse or whatever she's
doing now for now easy in a way just
listening to it is like others live it
and they love people getting answers
right like Andrews kind of getting some
answers about where Molly is East is
getting some interested about where
Nathan is and even Laurence is sort of
getting some answers about where either
ISA is and his stuff with condolence oh
I think it's really interesting
everybody is sort of getting a chance to
like say here's here's what the
situations are now what are you gonna do
this season specifically because you
brought up Lawrence's felt like very
much a set up season like I'm not trying
to say like we to wire some [ __ ] but
we're not just like what is this like
what is one of these white people and
see with these weapons even one and I
like this very much in season three
we've been planting a lot of seeds to
grow in season four with you know
Lawrence obviously considering so
considering like given what happened
with Chad and him going back to leave
just like should I can I go back and
then getting his answer hmm I can't go
back I'm gonna pursue it in this way and
what that's gonna lead to to season for
him and obviously and you're Nathan
living together in Mali pursue you
Andrew what that means we're even
and even Issa and Molly's relationship
so it's very excited to see where we're
gonna take things in the future for sure
what was fun about that is typically
we've always had you know their
relationships is like okay Easter day in
this guy mom's dating this guy and we're
never the twain shall sort of needs and
what's interesting now is like what
would this friendship be like and
they've always shared stuff and when is
this like if he's like well I don't want
to share with me that's gonna do it I
don't want my way to have a judgment at
Maui if she did Andrew like you know so
it'll be fun to see how this dynamic
could be plays out it sounds really
messy guys guys and then one and then
would have one relationship works out
better than the other two
thank you guys all for joining us for
wine grounds this season we love making
this season and hope you enjoyed it as
much as we did
so Cheers yeah shots at home
you